Sala found a city where two people are ranking in GMBs, but not in the organic CPC and search
volume fit the criteria. Should I go for it? So that, that one right there, I would go a little
bit further Sala. So what, what they're saying is they found a city where there's the two people
that keep ranking over and over in the GMB. So that's kind of a red flag because ideally you
want it to be mixed up, mixed up, mixed up, but that's, that's fine. But this, but they're also
saying that the, in the organic rankings, they're not showing up on page one for those same terms.
That's a good thing, but I would take it a step further and I would go look at those same companies,
sorry, I would go look at the companies that are ranking on page one organically.
And let's say the top two competitors and look at their backlinks, how many I would look at maybe
like how much domain authority or how much, what's the other term that we use? Trust flow
is the other one. If you use majestic, remember guys, we talked about backlinks like three weeks
in a row. I would look at the quality of the backlinks. I'd also look at the age of the domain
and I would just look at a couple of different factors before I just automatically assume in
this situation though, I would be happy to take a look at it for you Sala. If that would make you
feel better, make sure to message me, Ashley and fix it on a group thread. Great question.